[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  isn't that why we formed the justice  league to do what's right  protecting the monsters look who you're  standing  everyone has to make their own choice  about this oh so now he's god from what  i've heard most of the magical heroes  feel the same way superman you've had an  unfathomable loss you need time to  process  let yourself fall apart  you took his wife  you took his unborn child  why after all these years bassey you  really need reasons from me  now that's  a french line  what happened to metropolis can never be  allowed to occur again  i won't be held back by ideals that  don't protect the innocent  you'll throw away everything the justice  league stands for  you're his best friend talk to him  superman has created a police state he  needs to be stopped the laws of superman  will not be the laws of atlantis this  time the jokes are new  i thought i could redeem you  i was wrong  [Music]  you